see but that's what I'm saying you just
did there you belittled what women have
to do you belittled it my dear sister
look look did you did you I wonder why
that is maybe it's all the
responsibilities we have maybe it's the
fact that we take care of the household
and the children and
you do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training now is a a topic that's quite
it can make sissors emotional they don't
understand but can we look at the bigger
picture because look there are things in
Islam that doesn't make me happy can I
mention some of them to you or for
example the fact that I'm the
maintaining protector okay why am I the
maintaining protector why can't my wife
be the maintain protector accept that
nowadays yes in the modern world that's
not even realistic for the man to be the
exclusive provider but he has to the ISS
of austerity because of the cost of
living women have to work too contri too
so what difference is there between us
other than your ability to physically
protect me okay so what I'm saying I
understand my so what I'm saying is the
following a woman a Muslim woman has
every right to tell her husband I do not
want to work and you have to provide for
me and he has
to do you think Islam if we look at it
from from a liberal point of view do you
think that is
fair do I believe that it's fair so so
that the woman has the right a Muslim
woman has the right I think both should
agree to what they contribute I happy
with that agreement okay we we we we
agree to what Allah has commanded us
which is the following that the Muslim
woman has the right to tell her husband
you have to be the Sole Provider now
would you agree that that will put a lot
of burden on the man oh man um it
depends on the context so for example in
the western world no but now it's it's
more difficult for one man to go and
work especially when yeah I I took a
screenshot of it that's fine we're
talking about so what I'm saying is just
just so we can understand yeah that
Islam there's this notion that Islam
favors men that's not true Islam in
Islam a Muslim woman has every right to
tell her husband I do not want to work
anymore I want to be a housewife and I
want you to fully provide in the liberal
point of view um can you not no no no no
it's it's going to blur you it's my
camera man it's it's going to blur you
yeah yeah so yeah s yeah so my point is
this my dear sister is the following a
Muslim woman has has the right to tell
her husband you have to be the sole
provider and I'm staying at home looking
after the kids is that fair on the
man from the Lial point of view I'm
going to go work and you're going to be
at home with the kids and you
know I think that um you you say you
don't you don't like the fact that
that's exclusive your burden to carry I
have no problem cuz Allah commanded but
I'm seeing from a liberal point of view
is that fair for a man for I don't know
your name my name is Ali sister what's
your name sorry Ali Ali yeah what's your
name sister um s sister s may Allah
bless you in where you from sister I'm
from India origin oh okay and you're
born Muslim yeah yeah so so Ali you
started with oh there are some things
about Islam that make me uncomfortable
such as the fact that I'm exclusively
the provider and the protector okay you
said that right I didn't say
uncomfortable I'm happy with that to
that effect words that cuz that can you
accept it you accept it I fully embrace
it and I know it's difficult I have to
exactly but you think it's difficult
have you ever thought about how
difficult it is to exclusively be
responsible for the children and the
household how much of a toll that can
take because you're the educator and you
have more of an impact on those children
emotionally and otherwise than your
husband does have you ever thought about
that responsibility I I accept that I
when you go to work and you provide you
can clock out whenever you clock out for
women raising children is a 24/7
responsibility there is no downtime
whatsoever not only does she look after
the children but she has to take care of
you too you know rub your feet cook for
you Etc whatever whim you know you may
have she appeases because she's the
obedient wife have you guys thought
about the the a women's role and how
difficult that might be too so it's not
a question of oh it's difficult for you
it's difficult for both of us I I I've
never said that it's not difficult for
both of us you came from the angle as if
it's only difficult for the woman and
not the man that's why I mentioned that
I didn't I I didn't come and say I
didn't say woman don't have it hard I
framing you the way you framing this
scenario is actually women don't have to
do much cuz they don't have to go out
into the world and work that's our
responsibility they could just sit at
home you know play with the kids but
it's not that simple is it I never said
that anything it's harder for women I
wouldn't say it's harder for women
taking care of the children I wouldn't
say it's hard for women because you do
realize that for example I have a mother
you know with what you can comp with
what you can compartmentalize women
can't compartmentalize we're working
24/7 okay sister so let's just break
this down cuz let's just not speak of
each other let's break it down do you
agree that a man for example is the sole
responsible for his wife in what sense
that's very open open-ended like to
provide and protect for her yeah Pro
providing and protecting Okay good does
he also need to protect and provide for
his daughter
and yeah and his son before he's of age
not necessarily but I'm talking a
certain level a woman needs a guardian
from the moment she's born till the day
she dies do I need to also look after my
mother so why does Saudi Arabia say you
can do h i don't follow Saudi Arabia I
follow Islam so my dear sister a man has
to look after his mother his sister his
daughter and his wife so when you come
and say it's to his wife no it's not
look after you no no my sister I never
said you don't I'm not having a a gender
War here by saying I do more and you
don't the reason I'm saying that is I'm
trying to make you understand from our
perspective the issue was polygamy and
you said it is difficult for us women
and I said 100% I've never said it's not
but if we look at the bigger picture
there are things that we are told to do
as men that for example it's it causes
we can even lose our life for example
when it comes to war we are told to go
to war now I can come and say well why
am I going to war why don't you go to
war why don't my wife go to war why
don't you guys go I'll sit at home and
make
Biryani see what I'm saying you just did
that the you belittled what women have
to do you belittled it my dear sister
look look did you did you did you Bel
little did you little how often do you
have to go to war see this is what I'm
saying in a if I go to war once in a
lifetime that's once in a lifetime death
all right do do you know statistically
that married women die sooner than
married men do you know sta married
women die married women die sooner as
far as I know married men as as speaking
I wonder why that is maybe it's all the
responsibilities we have maybe it's the
fact that we take care of the household
and the children and you and our
brothers and our sisters Our Father you
have no right to take care of my dear
sister look let's just let's just break
this down do because islamically we're
taught to care for every human our
proximity why are we making this agenda
what I'm trying to say to you there are
things Allah has prescribed for you that
we really told women when you said all I
had to do
is sister sister sister please listen to
understand me not listen to reply I said
to you war is not a joke there are
bullets flying towards you there's
Rockets grenades dis with okay good so
I'm saying the following to your logic
I'm saying there are things if I was to
use my liberal mind frame that is seems
more oppressive to men than women if I
wish to look at Islam and say hold on a
second let's weigh up the
responsibilities of a man and a woman
which one has it worse off I would say
men why because we have to go to war
when there when I'm walking down with my
wife and a man tries to say something I
have to put my life on the line fight
him and even die at the course by
defending her cuz she's not physically
strong and then when it comes to uh many
other things responsibilities not only
for my is your wife you go to my dear
sister it is not about how often I go to
war cuz I can go to war I can go to war
on edgear road with two guys who's got a
knife who's trying to kill my wife and I
have to put my life on the line so I'm
also for example when there this ship in
sink sister who goes first the men or
the children of women the men do no no
men don't no men die no women I mean
thank you so what I'm saying is we have
no problem with that as men I've never
suggested that men and women are
literally the same what I'm saying is
that you're making it seem as ISL but I
think we all have we both have equal
burdens what I'm say thank you I want to
say equal I would I would I would to say
it's equal I think we both go through
different trials but all I'm trying to
say is this I don't want to have a
gender war and you against me you're my
sister in Islam I'm just saying this
issue of polygamy which is troubling for
you I understand that but what I'm
saying is my dear sister is that we
cannot come and say Islam is oppressive
or Islam is not because no I never said
you did I'm speaking generally I never
said I've never said the sister does
that yeah I'm just saying my dear sister
when it comes to polygamy polygamy has
come to protect the right of a woman how
because there are men who had the
propensity to one more than one woman so
if you look at nonm Muslim woman tell me
something I don't know yeah well I don't
know if you know or not I just met you s
tell me tell me why um what's the issue
exactly no I'm just trying to understand
um the quran's treatment of women in
some respects okay let's talk about it
what what are some things that the first
scenario that um I don't necessarily
find troubling but um I I'm struggling
to understand is um the testimony of one
man is equivalent of two women why yeah
yeah given we're intellectually the same
no no okay no no firstly who said we are
intellectually same like what what do
you mean by intellectually same right so
men might use certain aspects of their
brain in different ways to women and
vice versa but you have your strengths
and we have our strength so generally
speaking intellectually we are the same
we're just as intellectually capable as
men Okay no Okay so for what I'm say
when you're talking about int for
example that's why Islam allows a woman
to work so in certain areas Islam
doesn't say a woman cannot work no no
exactly no no no no exactly but was not
like those boss business women of today
please let's not get KH yeah trust me no
because there's a lot of sister trust me
she obeyed she obeyed her husband she
was obedient to her husband she's the
one who proposed in a decent manner to
her husband she married a man that the
prophet peace be upon him and guess what
she picked him to manage her Affairs in
the business today today today today
woman today's I'm not generaliz all I'm
not generalizing all but what I'm saying
is my dear sister is that that's the
thing now you said something about now
as men and women we're different do you
do understand that you have no I'm
coming to testimony sister yeah okay so
when it comes to for example this woman
go through Mena sorry the do woman go to
men menopause okay good do they have
periods okay these periods have an
effect on the emotional imbalances is
that correct some women but so what you
mean some women yeah some wom Every Man
Has testosterone here sister women are
impacted by PMS some are some are free
of PMS I'm a woman I know other women
and I know know me telling men are not
impacted by testesterone he has extreme
and even there studies that show when it
comes to uh intimacy for example the way
a man's desire towards a woman it's not
the same so basically you're saying
you're saying that there's a discrepancy
there with tesy because
women no no no I'm just sorry say that
again yeah because we're we're not
always in control okay good so what I'm
saying is that Allah subhana is
acknowledge that woman has her moments
when there's emotional instability okay
so this is this is there's nothing to
wrong with this going to affect your
testimony no no no sister let me tell
you something when you stand in court if
you saw a murder right happen right in
front of us yeah now let's give a
scenario if you saw the witness for
example a man came and put fre bullets
in the man's head and shot him down on
the floor bang bang bang bang bang you
are a woman yes there's another sister
you a Muslim sister okay so we got two
sisters here you saw it the moment you
hear that bang bang here everyone is
ducking out but more of the men because
it's in our nature we want to know
what's going on can I protect my family
I'm on protective mode now for a woman
like you saw Trump's bodyguard yeah that
woman yeah she was jump she was jump she
was trying to save her life
understandable now why because as men we
have no problem being the protect and
dying for our family it's in our blood
we love it we dying for our family no
problem so the point is this my sister
when this murder happens emotionally
unable no no no I never said that I
never said that
I'm saying there's emotional
imbalances however you want so what I'm
saying is sister so so so one second so
what I'm saying is that Allah says if
One S the other can correct them and
it's not just
for it's not just for uring it comes to
also it can be the issue of finances
because women were not tend to known to
be the providers so when it came to
issues of maybe let's say inheritance
money kind of stuff so Allah has enabled
Allah has enabled that exactly so
exactly but it also applies to so what
I'm saying is Sister Allah just put that
there to even now Sister Allah has
acknowledged that woman has weaknesses
in certain places and no sister you are
an exception Allah deals with a general
rule no no sister let me tell you
something when when when Allah thank you
very much I appreciate your time no no
no no and your I'm not one speak it's
just I have to go thank you very much
[Applause]
I mean there's nothing else to say but
yeah we're trying to ask the
misconception but you know what it is
sometimes is that sadly with our sisters
not all of them but it's just defense
just defense like can we just talk
understand each other these verses and
this the issue that we're facing
feminism and red PE has destroyed that
so much so that anything that you say
it's become misogynistic it's become you
know you're trying to say we're
emotionally unstable it's a reality
Allah subhana T has said that there's
responsibilities there's hormons that I
have that cause issues for me so the
point is alhamd we follow Islam we don't
change Islam and yeah that's what I want
say I tried to explain to the sister but
obviously she had her setbacks but she's
our sister in ISD and for those S
watching at home maybe it answers your
questions alum